im griff der polizei bei demonstrationen
gegen präsident putin gibt es in
russland tausende festnahm
für bessere planung vor dem impfgipfel
morgen fordern die bundesländer genaue
zeitpläne und mehr impfstoff auf den
plätzen eins bis vier die deutschen
frauen fahren allen davon wurde
weltmeisterin ist erstmals julia taubitz
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster
wir kommen bei unserem
nachrichtenüberblick am sonntag sport
gibt es auch mit norbert lehmann
angelina wort von mir und wir beginnen
heute in russland wo die menschen weiter
für die freiheit von kremlkritiker
navalny und gegen putin massenhaft auf
die straße gehen und das obwohl die
polizei nach angaben von
menschenrechtlern wieder mehr als 4000
menschen festgenommen hat darunter auch
navis ehefrau der protest gegen putin in
der hauptstadt moskau aber auch in
vielen anderen städten wie
beispielsweise hier in sankt petersburg
oder in nowosibirsk in sibirien
viele demonstranten und die schlagstöcke
der staatsmacht wie erwartet reagierte
die polizei mit härte aus russland
christiansen hart durchgreifen schon vor
offiziellen beginn der demonstrationen
am mittag in moskau
das ist die antwort der staatsmacht auf
die nicht genehmigten proteste immer
wieder ziehen sie demonstrierende aus
der menge und schleifen sie in
gefangenen busse die minusgrade und der
schnee halten die menschen nicht davon
ab wieder auf die straße zu gehen
heute sind die eindrücke sehr negativ
unsere macht hat schon so eine angst vor
ihrem volk dass sie nicht weiß was sie
machen soll
navalny als politiker unterstütze ich
nicht so sehr ich denke einfach dass es
einen politischen prozess braucht man
braucht politische konkurrenz die
moskauer innenstadt abgeriegelt
geschäfte und restaurants geschlossen
metro stationen werden gesperrt der
internet empfang ist gestört
eigentlich wollten die demonstrierenden
vor der zentrale des
inlandsgeheimdienstes fsb protestieren
unweit des kreml
doch bis dahin kamen sie nicht navalny
steam rief die menschen dazu auf sich an
anderen plätzen der millionenmetropole
zu versammeln
verteilt auf stadtgebiet
in rund 100 städten russland weit gingen
wieder tausende menschen auf die straße
protest festnahmen und gewalt in elf
zeitzonen in sankt petersburg
wladiwostok jekaterinburg oder wie hier
in die akkus in sibirien
ich mag wirklich keine lügner diebe und
all das mein ganzes leben schon nicht
heute sagten sie dass sie sich dagegen
versammeln würden also bin ich gekommen
so unterschiedlich die menschen in
russland aus sind so gleich klingen ihre
wünsche nach veränderung in moskau ist
für über gar für uns filme können diese
proteste putin denkt gefährlich werden
also wenn man sich die ereignisse des
heutigen tages anschaut dann muss man
davon ausgehen dass der kreml diese
proteste sehr ernst nimmt
schon stunden vor beginn waren große
teile der moskauer innenstadt
abgeriegelt
die protestierenden haben sich dann an
anderen orten getroffen einer davon war
dieser jemand hier hinter mir sieht die
polizei hat sie auch von hier vertrieben
es gab viele festnahmen manche davon
ziemlich brutal ganz ähnliche szenen
jahr aus anderen städten russlands
wenn man dann noch die
einschüchterungsversuche der letzten
tage dazu nimmt die reihenweise
verhaftungen von navis mitstreiter in
seinen familienangehörigen oder auch nur
sympathisanten dann scheint es so dass
die russische staatsmacht sich dazu
entschieden hat diese protestbewegung im
keim ersticken zu wollen bevor sie
bloody mir putin womöglich gefährlich
werden könnte vielen dank für nach
moskau zum thema corona da gehen die
zahlen ja erfreulicherweise weiter nach
unten wenn nur die sorge wegen der hoch
ansteckenden mutanten nicht wäre
darum setzt die bundesregierung ja auf
das impfen aber das geht nicht voran
weil nachschub fehlt die kritik an
diesen zuständen wird immer lauter sie
kommen vor allem aus den ländern vor dem
morgigen krisengipfel mit der kanzlerin
fordern sie einen verlässlichen fahrplan
frank buchwald ihre impfung kam zu spät
das virus war schon da als die menschen
in diesem seniorenheim endlich ihre
spritze bekamen 15 von ihnen starben
weitere 47 menschen sind infiziert alle
meta britischen mutante tragischer fall
aus leverkusen
impfen aber längst ein reizthema
schuldzuweisungen jedoch so minister
sparen helfe niemandem
landräte kritisieren ministerpräsidenten
und landesminister landesminister
kritisieren bundesminister und die
bundesregierung die bundesregierung
kritisiert die europäische kommission
und alle zusammen kritisieren die
hersteller das virus ist der feind der
gegner viele impfzentren aber stehen
leer der impfstoff fehlt die
ministerpräsidenten frustriert wir sind
vorbereitet mit impfzentren und mobilen
teams wir kommen gut voran in den
ländern und nun fehlen uns die nächsten
lieferungen las bund und länder und
kommunen ja gemeinsam schaffen wollen
ist dass wir möglichst viele menschen
impfen und es geht eben nur wenn man
auch weiß übertreibe wochen hinaus wie
viel impfstoff kommt wann die grünen
gehen noch weiter sie wollen die
hersteller stärker an die kandare nehmen
die pharmaindustrie hat natürlich ein
ökonomisches interesse und wir haben
öffentliche interesse und das ist nicht
automatisch gesagt dass beides exakt
übereinander passt ein bisschen sollte
die bundesregierung sehr strengen drauf
gucken welche kapazitäten noch an
welchen stellen hochgefahren werden
können
patientenschützer fordern vor allem
klarheit entscheidend ist dass wir den
menschen keine versprechen machen die
nicht gehalten werden können
große erwartungen also an dass bund
länder treffen morgen nachmittag merkel
und die ministerpräsidenten unter druck
morgen also der imz gipfel mit der
kanzlerin was kann denn dabei
herauskommen theo nun ich glaube selten
sind forderungen und erwartbare
erfüllung so weit auseinander gewesen
wie bei diesem impfgipfel der
regierungssprecher hat schon im vorfeld
davor gewarnt konkrete beschlüsse zu
erwarten aber die forderungen werden von
stunde zu stunde lauter und dringlicher
und sind natürlich auch ausdruck der
massiven frustration über die
ausbleibenden impfstoffe frustration
sowohl beim bürger als auch bei denen
die impfzentren betreiben also bei den
ländern nach einem vollen jahr der
pandemie nach einem jahr der
einschränkung wird impfen gleichgesetzt
mit einem ende der krise und der
persönlichen einschränkungen und das
macht das versagen in der ausreichenden
impfstoffversorgung so dramatisches wird
morgen um lösungssuche gehen es sind ja
auch alle pharmafirmen vertreten aber
natürlich geht es auch um das schon
begonnen
und herschieben von verantwortung das
anlaufende war ja lässt grüßen
theo koll mit dem ausblick auf morgen
vielen dank dafür nach berlin
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen hat noch mal die strategie bei
der impfstoff bestellung verteidigt ihr
ziel sei es dass bis zum ende des
sommers 70 prozent der erwachsenen in
europa geimpft sein sagte sie dem zdf
das ganze gespräch sehen sie im heute
journal um viertel vor ziehen wenn
flugpassagiere aus corona risikogebieten
nach deutschland kommen sind genaue
kontrollen vorschrift die
fluggesellschaften hielten sich aber oft
nicht daran kritisiert bundespolizei
präsident roman verantwortungslos nennt
er das und spricht gegenüber der bild am
sonntag von 600 verstößen in den letzten
sechs tagen etwa von passagieren ohne
digitale anmeldung oder ohne chor ohne
test der winter teil deutschland weiter
in zwei hälften der norden weist der
süden nass an rhein main und an der
donau hochwasser verursacht durch regen
und schneeschmelze steigende pegelstände
werden auch an der mosel erwartet
gefrorene gewässer dagegen in der börde
bei wolfsburg und der fichtelberg im
erzgebirge ein idol in klirrender kälte
weites land im eis gewarnt
und schon sind wir beim wintersport und
den deutschen erfolgen bei der rodel-wm
arbeit da gab es silber in der
team-staffel und einen vierfach erfolg
der frauen im einsitzer julia davids
erstmals weltmeisterin
die erfolgsbilanz des deutschen teams am
königssee vier wm-titel insgesamt zwölf
medaillen
das freudentänzchen von julia taubitz
nach einer galavorstellung bei den
weltmeisterschaften am königssee zwei
tage nach ihrem sieg im sprint
wettbewerb zeigt die
gesamtweltcupsiegerin des vergangenen
winters erneut zwei ganz starke läufe am
ende gewinnt die 24 jährige erstmals den
wm-titel im einsitzer und das deutlich
mit über drei zehntelsekunden vorsprung
von natalie geisenberger mit david
berger auf dem bronzerang wollen die
deutschen rodlerinnen den kompletten
dahlien satz und auch beim bob weltcup
finale in innsbruck ein weiterer
deutscher vor francesco friedrich im
siegesrausch der rekordweltmeister
gewann heute auch im vierten und letzten
viererbob wettkampf vor den teams aus
österreich und kanada
friedrich hat damit in dieser
weltcup-saison 15 von 16 wettbewerben
gewonnen
eric frenzel hat zum abschluss des
nordic triple in seefeld einen
podestplatz verpasst der kombinierer war
als viertplatzierter der beste deutsche
sieger der norweger jan magnus lieber
aufs podest geschafft hat es dagegen
markus eisenbichler zum abschluss des
skisprung weltcups in willingen
der 29 jährige erkämpfte sich einen
starken dritten platz und das unter
schwierigen windbedingungen die nur
einen sprung durchgang für alle athleten
zu lösen sieger des tages der norweger
halvard granold mit seinem weiten satz
von 149 metern zweiter wurde der pole
piotr zyla und dänemark hat soeben den
weltmeistertitel in ägypten verteidigt
als handball weltmeister besiegt
schweden mit 26 zu 24 dank genauer am
schluss noch kurz die wetteraussichten
östlich der elbe freundlich sonst meist
stark bewölkt und etwas regen im
nordosten auch schnee höchstwerte von
minus zwei bis plus zehn grad so viel
von uns im heute journal um 21.45
spricht claus kleber auch mit dem
ehemaligen us präsidenten obama
wir sagen danke dass sie dabei waren